in this challenge episode we're going to
attempt the 20 candle extinguishing shot
team up with the world's best
trampolineers and more let's get into it
first one to miss the cop losers solve
200 cops don't miss the shot
[Music]
all right it shouldn't be that hard
what if you lose this we have to come up
with the punishment what does smash to
the back
oh
we know it comes hard
don't miss them
I'm not gonna miss
that was so close was that a good
strategy no it wasn't I think this is
the best oh we almost came back
you can say that don't worry guys I got
your back
at least he's doing the warm I'm already
filming off his smash
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much okay what record are
you using Houston Rockets okay
okay
yeah that hurts that hurts
next we're going to blow out as many
candles as possible in one single shot
first one I heard that you tried to blow
out three candles but it never happened
we tried four different days or
something like get a triple candle but
never got it but I have to say this is a
bit easier we're gonna do at least 20
today
huh he came back alive it's very
convenient because
oh there we have it I can't believe that
it worked this is the first world pick
that we ever did like the candle this is
the thing where it started for us that
went viral like completely viral please
show us six
what's this
oh
my God okay six seems to be too easy
we're going straight to 10. I wonder how
far we can take this
at least 20.
oh
but that's the new record that's the new
record eight burning
oh yeah I think so too this is the there
is no way this is happening
we're jumping from 10 to 20. yeah just
like
it's nine only
oh
is that on your record it's 11. it's 11.
hey a new world record 11. but we're not
happy with that no we're not happy
it's a new recorder
it's 9 10 11. 12.
[Applause]
oh we got it
come on let's go
I guess 12 is the new world record of
this from ankle hunt wrist awaits
[Music]
hit the hardest that you can
hard
harder harder yeah that's good
how many do you want well as many as you
can fit there maximum speed forehand
let's see what you got
that's that's decent I feel like I
didn't even move my hands the final
weight of the puzzle in total you have
24 kilos added weights
I'm hitting as hard as I can I felt like
I was in a slow motion Movie all the
time now you'll be super interesting to
see him play without the weight
oh look at him like I've never seen him
move like that
so the next challenge we're joined by
the world's best trampoline is Radio
flips we're gonna do a flip over the
table and hit it on I think we can make
it work yeah morning
[Music]
that was incredible
first try oh my God
oh no
[Music]
okay
that's insane
oh it's scary close to the bar yeah
oh
we got it he's up there like at least
four or five minutes
one more
shot so now we're gonna double back
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah okay okay
that's incredible oh
um
[Applause]
yeah
oh
oh no
what from out of nowhere
all right cheers to radial flips go and
check out their YouTube channel go check
out my Clips on our Channel if you want
to see more flips like this
oh whoa
whoa